Speaker 1: The degree to which faux populist
rhetoric and the propagandistic nature of
Tucker Carlson's Fox News program has completely
bamboozled a huge portion of the American
right wing, and even some on the left is really
an important issue to be explored.
There are even people who are already talking
about Tucker Carlson for Republican presidential
nominee and 2024.
And based on just how easily people are falling
for Tucker's nonsense, it does not bode well
for the United States in the sense that it's
clear Tucker is able to put together propaganda
and disinformation that is really effective
in the current marketplace of ideas and ignorance
and a complete absence of thought on the American
right.
And one of the reasons that Tucker Carlson
is so effective is that he is sort of the
anti intellectuals, pseudo intellectual.
And what I mean by that is Tucker Carlson
has a way of talking to people that don't
understand anything or know anything, which
makes him seem like a really smart, enlightened
and even borderline intellectual guy.
And the reason it works is that when Tucker
puts out some idea about economics, sociology,
people who watch it have never studied those
areas before.
They have no frame of reference for comparison.
And so Tucker sounds convincing and they fall
for it, whereas a more informed person would
hear Tucker and say, you know, the things
Tucker is opining about are completely outside
of his area of expertize they've already been
widely studied.
Tucker's ideas are half baked and ignorant.
And we already know about all of these things.
Tucker is merely, quote, asking questions
about.
So here's one example to really make it a
more tangible for you.
This is from a recent Tucker episode on Fox
News.
And in this one, Tucker starts putting out
the idea that, you know, changes to societies
are really, really bad.
And it's all fundamentally rooted in Tucker
Carlson's anti-immigration nationalist ideas,
which he masks as a populist rhetoric.
People are falling for it hook, line and sinker.
So let's dove in and think through some of
what's being said.
Speaker 3: If you're over 40, you may have
trouble recognizing your own country.
It's just too unfamiliar.
Now, the self-righteous children on social
media don't care to notice this, and when
they do, they dismiss it.
Any complaint about change as bigotry.
But it's not bigotry.
It's human nature.
Abrupt change causes social chaos always.
Speaker 1: So they're like four or five different
things there that are that are pretty nonsensical,
but they're all thrown together and people
fall for it.
He says people over 40 might not recognize
this country anymore.
He says abrupt change causes social chaos.
The reality is that there isn't much abrupt
change happening of the type that Tucker is
describing.
It's really common as a trope for the reactionary
right to say things are changing too quickly
and it's for the worse.
We're losing control of what we used to have,
which was better, and we are quickly on some
kind of ramp to something much worse.
The reality is that the country today is different
than it was in the 90s, which was much different
than during the 60s and 70s, which had already
changed significantly from the supposed conservative
golden era of the 1950s, which was already
different than the sort of pre and during
World War Two era where there were big changes
relative to the time between the two world
wars, which was already different from what
the country looked like before World War One.
And then before that, you're in the late eighteen
hundreds where things were really different.
We were pricker, we were privation, we were
in the industrial revolution.
Things are always changing and there's always
guys like Tucker screaming that the changes
to quit too quick and it's bad and we're quickly
going down in flames and it's ripping apart
the fabric of the country.
Now, it is true that most human societies
let me put a different way.
Many human societies have failed, but for
different reasons.
And America may fail.
And I'm going to get back to that.
But Tucker's refrain is a tired old refrain
that at this point is just boring to anyone
who has studied the rise and fall of societies
and civilizations.
But we'll get back to that.
Let's look at another clip.
Speaker 3: Human beings develop customs and
habits and generational expectations for a
reason.
It's not random.
Continuity is comforting to people.
If you eliminate familiar things overnight,
societies, fracture populations tend to explode.
We've seen that happen.
The last industrial revolution in the end
provoked armed revolutions.
Hundreds of millions of people died.
Germany got Hitler, Eastern Europe got Stalinism.
Yes, we did wind up with antibiotics.
In the end, you can thank technology for that.
And we do.
But we also got genocide and atomic bombs.
Speaker 1: This is absolutely bonkers.
This is so off the wall that it's actually
hard to even know how to start picking it
apart because it just makes no sense.
Tucker's throwing things together there that
are barely related.
And here's the thing, and this goes back to
what I said at the beginning of the segment.
There are lots of people watching, Tucker,
who simply have never thought about these
topics in these terms.
It's similar to when a college freshman that
has never been exposed to any economics goes
to micro 101 and suddenly they are neoclassical
economics believers.
They believe that neoclassical standard economics,
that it's all there is that it's right.
That's it.
Then, though, you start to learn about other
economic theory.
You read some behavioral economics, you read
some Marx, you get a wider view.
And then you come to realize, well, the first
thing I heard isn't always or necessarily
correct on this issue.
You would be vaccinated for lack of a better
term against Tucker's nonsense.
If you had previously read some of this stuff,
for example, the work of Jared Diamond.
This is not dense academic stuff.
Jared Diamond's work on why societies fail
or succeed is very accessible.
And if you were familiar with that, just that.
And of course, there's there's dozens, hundreds
of other things that would have insulated
you where you would hear Tucker say this.
You would say this guy has no idea what he's
talking about.
The arguments he's making are not based in
history, historical fact.
They're not based on anything other than Tucker's
wishes as to what he wants the United States
to look like.
This is just one example.
But you would then not be falling for just
any old thing Tucker says about societal change
and what hurts or helps a culture.
You would be protected because you would have
some knowledge from actual experts on this
issue.
Let's watch a little more of the clip.
Speaker 3: There's a lesson here, if you're
going to change things, go slowly, choose
the incremental over the immediate, explain
yourself as you do it, reassure people, acknowledge
the reality of evolutionary biology.
It is real.
Human beings are not born to be machine components.
You can't just bang out improved versions
of your citizens on a 3D printer.
People in real life are complicated and stubborn
and hard to control, even the most open minded
ones get jumpy when suddenly everything's
different.
Speaker 1: The truth is, just about everything
is changing incrementally.
It's not really changing rapidly.
I mean, you know, sociologist Tucker Carlson
is feeding you drivel here.
Look at health care.
Look at how slowly it has changed.
It took basically 20 years to get the Affordable
Care Act.
Remember, the Affordable Care Act under a
different name and put together by different
people was first floated in the early 90s.
It took basically 20 years to get that.
And that is a relatively modest change to
the system.
Look at societal views on gay marriage, which
shifted so slowly over decades, legalization
in a few states, then eventually full legalization
in 2015.
We are only now getting to the point where
more than half the country supports gay marriage,
thanks to some more Republicans getting on
on board.
So the change has been slow by modern standards.
It is true that humanity in the last 500 years
has changed very quickly compared to the slow
evolution of Homo sapiens over millions of
years.
But Tucker is not talking about that in a
global sense.
He's talking about cultural norms in the United
States.
Here's the last piece of the segment.
OK, so, you know, this is the type of rant
that leads conservatism into the ideology
of preserved society as it is merely because
change is scary and we assume bad.
And short of that, Tucker says the new technology
is mostly good, but don't change society along
with it.
And that that also makes no sense.
Anybody who has read about technological change
and here again, very accessible.
I'm going off the top of my head.
Look at the work of Max Tegmark, a look at
the work of Bill Bryson.
And, you know, I'm kind of blanking here,
but there's so much accessible stuff on this
issue.
How could you have the technology, technological
acceleration that Tucker seems to say is good
but have no societal change either?
That also is completely ahistorical.
In fact, I just finished reading Karl Newport's
new book, A World Without Email, where he
talks about how because of email, a lot of
jobs have become 30, 40, 50, 60 percent, just
managing in an email inbox rather than doing
the work.
That's sort of core to what you do.
But one of the interesting things that Cal
Newport talks about is that email wasn't just
you have work and office culture and then
incomes email and now you have the same work
and office culture plus email.
It doesn't work that way.
Email actually changed in significant ways
over a period of 30 years.
Work culture and office culture and the nature
of work.
You can't have just you drop in a technological
change and nothing changes.
But Tucker wants you to believe the change
is out of control and it's for the worst.
And it could be the downfall of society.
And this is what people have been saying for
hundreds of years in the U.S.
The Industrial Revolution was going to be
it, you know, cars, airplanes, women voting,
you know, whatever example you want to find,
you can find it.
And it's really one of the best examples,
this clip we looked at of what Tucker does
so well, but it only works effectively on
an ignorant audience that has no frame of
reference on these issues.
There's another new problem for the Republican
Party, which is
that college educated voters are abandoning
the party quite quickly, to a degree that
I didn't even realize